サッブパパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ サチッッタパリオダパナン エタング ブッダナ サーサナン
ではよろしくお願いします
前回は台風でしたけど
今回は大丈夫ですね まあ前回頑張ったおかげで
で 今日のテーマは あの
皆様の質問などにもね
できるだけ時間を置きたいので
まあ理解できてもできなくても
ものすごいスピードで喋って終わりにします
疑い落ちたらということですね
では 本当の自由に達するための義ということはね
どのように解消するのかと
サイドに書いてないんですけど
この英語で私たちは皆様も使わないんだけど
よく使う単語があります
このラショナルダウトというね
ラショナルダウト ラショナルというのは理性的ということでしょうかね
ダウトというのは疑いですね
いわゆるいい加減な疑いじゃなくて
理性的の疑い 単に頭ごなしに俺は信じませんよとかね
それは人格悪いんですね
もうちょっと理性的で理論的で
ちょっと怪しいなと感じることが
英語のフレーズとしてはすごくありがたいことで
この現代社会 この科学世界
この金具ばっかりもう潰されているような
この現代我々生きている世界が
この そういうラショナルダウトからね
理性的な疑いから現れた世界なんですね
だから人を言ったからといって信じません
特にヨーロッパというのは
知識的にすごい恐ろしいほど怖いほど後進的な国々でしたから
中東もそうなんですけど
あの昔そうじゃないんですね
エジプトとかね そういう時代もありましたからね
その時はそれなりに乗り越えたようで
一応新教が現れてきて
それから中東でイスラムが現れてきて
人間の脳みそを全部くたくた壊しちゃったんですね
だからこの 神の名のもとに人を殺すは
いわゆる野蛮人になってしまったんですね
だからコーランに逆らったら殺す
宗教イスラム教を変えたら直ちに殺す
キリスト教もそういうことをやってきたんですね
教会に逆らったら もう王様も出て行けという
しかし その宗教家たちがあまりも残酷で
もうなんか尊敬できない連中なんですね
一般人よりもひどいんですね
そういうことで みんななかなかこそこそと反対する気持ちも隠れて表れてきて
それからどんどんどんどんものは調べることになったんですね
だから この疑いから科学が始めたんですよ
疑いから疑い ラショナルダウト
理性的な疑いがあったから
我々はすごく今自由に生きているんですね
で 教会は全面的に人間を管理するということはないんですが
いまだにこの汚いあれ残ってはいるんですね
宗教 かなり政府から分離するというアメリカの憲法なんですけどね
憲法を作っていて ものすごく人間が平等であることをものすごく考えて
ある特定の宗教に信仰に何か力あるということはいけませんということで
立派に項目できているんだけど
アメリカの大統領バカたちが宣誓儀やってると
最後にそうヘルプミーゴッドと言っちゃうんですね
だから大統領職務が始まるあの時点で憲法違反しているんです
そう ヘルプミーゴッドバカじゃなくてね
そうヘルプミーと人間に頼まなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから人間協力しなきゃもうどうにもならんだからね
いくら大統領であっても
とにかくそういうこのだから選挙運動やっている人は
キリスト教でなければいけませんし
アメリカでも それでどんな宗派かって
これ結構厳しいんですね
だから日本だけじゃない
堂々と憲法違反やってるの
誰だってやってるみたいですね
他の国も同じことですけど
だからなんで我々はね
昔より一応楽に生きているし
まあいろんなもの 例えば病院に行ったら
何か変な工場に行ったような感じでしょ
機械 機械 機械 機械ばっかしで
だからそれでそれなりに人間の病気治そうとは頑張ってるんですね
体の内臓まで写真撮ってみる
脳みそまで写真撮ってみるとかね
教会だけ信じていたら
病気になったら祈りしかないんですね
だから義はありがたいんですよ
それで問題は 仏教もこの煩悩の一つとして義という言葉を使っているんですね
そこでこの単語がなかったと思います
別な単語があればいいんだけど
私は考えたのは普通の日本語でね
あの瞑想してサティに達すると
精神的な曖昧不安が消えるではないかなと思いますね
それは義がなくなると
第一のステージに悟ったら
で 義はありがたいことですが
義がなくなったら困るんだけどね
だから義という単語 パーリ語でも同じ単語を使ってるんだから
ちょっと まあ別な単語があっても構わないと思います
じゃあ話の内容に行きます
はい これから皆様知っている疑いのところはまあそんな程度で終わり
だからこの物事を鵜呑みにするなよと
人が言ったからといってね
乗るなよと 例えば日本の総理大臣の様であっても
言ったからといってね
乗ってはあかん なぜ世の中人間というのは
あの嘘を言うことはすごく素晴らしいことだと思っているんですね
嘘をつけなかったら立場がないんだと
だから 特に政治家っていうのは
世界中の政治家は嘘で自分の生計を立てているんですね
だから国民はどんな国の国民もろくなことないんです
幸せにならないんです
ものすごく不安で怯えて生活しなくちゃ
アメリカは自由な国と言うんだけど
根掘り葉掘り個人のデータを取って取って
個人の自由を残酷に侵しちゃっているんですね
だからメールだって調べる
だから政治家が国民が敵だと思っているならば
これは理性的な政治じゃないでしょうに
アメリカは皆様知ってるんだから
アメリカを例に出すんだけど
別に アメリカだけ悪人というわけじゃないんです
それを覚えておいてください
ですから この我々一人一人が身を守らなくちゃいけないんですよ
誰も守ってくれません
宗教はもう完全嘘の世界で
で 儀式 儀式があるわ 祈祷があるわ
イエス様っていうのはストーリーなんですが
この祈祷師なんですね
だから作ったストーリーだから
歴史的にいた人格ではないんです
だから この後で信仰が固定したら
いろんな場所 ここで生まれたとかね
いろいろ後で作ったんですけど
あれは厳しい考古学的には成り立たないと
質問 まあそれはいいんだけど
だからストーリーはダブっちゃって
たまに頭のいいことも言ったり
たまに本当に原始的な祈祷師やったりとかね
だから人間の考えはそれなりに適当にまとめただけやと思いますけどね
だからこの 何であろうとも
なんか信頼できない 自分の命を自分で守らなくちゃいけないというね
誰かが守ってくれるわけじゃないということがあるんだから
やっぱり理がありがたいんですね
要するに 自分で判断して
自分で責任を持って考えてみるというね
それは仏教だ たとえ師匠の話であってもね
うのみにするなよと 議論してみなさいと
自分の意見も出してみてよと
そこで納得しなくちゃあかんですね
この言葉がわかりやすく答える
自分自身で納得しなくちゃいけないんですね
だから人類からそれは消えているんですね
特に仏教の世界も宗教だからね
嘘ですからね 全部 で 師匠に弟子入りしたら
無条件で言うことを何でもはいはいはいと言わなくちゃあかんですね
これでは衰退するのは結果で
成長はしません 師匠たちが困るのは
お前らがね もう偉大なる伝統を壊すのではないかと
もし偉大なる伝統がありがたいものだったら
これは生存しますよ そんな簡単に壊せません
簡単に壊れるものだったら
ろくなものじゃないんです
だから脅して 伝統を守れ
しきたりを守れというのはね
その言葉自体で大したことないという証拠でしょ
罰が当たるんだよと 罰が当たるので誰もやりませんよ
脅さなくても だから本当のところ罰が当たりません
だって我々は火は触りませんね
電気流れていると 開けて中
機械開けて中触ろうとしない
なぜ？罰が当たるんだから
だから罰が当たるを知っているんだから
ちゃんと身を守っていますよ
鍋で料理を作っていると手で取る
あれは手で取りません
ミトン使いますね なんで？罰が当たりますよ
だから罰が当たるならば
人間知っているんです
それにしたら宗教世界のこうやってはいけない
ああやってはいけない
もう罰が当たりますよという話です
だからその時点で嘘ばっかりということでしょう
皆様にそういうふうに考える自由がないね
かわいそう だから脅して脅されて
我々は文化を守る けしからんです
我々一人一人が納得して
文化を守るならば それはすごくいいことなんですね
だから仏教でお釈迦様が言うポイントは納得しなさいよと
例えば なんで親に自分の子供を躾できないんですかね
この連中もなんか宗教家みたいな感じで一方的にしゃべる
そんな権利ないでしょうに
いくら子供が小さいからといって
子供を自分が養うからといって
生命は平等で みんなに平等に権利があるんです
だからやっぱり対等で喋って納得してもらわなくちゃいけないんですね
親がね 子供 自分の子供を叱責しなくちゃいけない
教師が生徒たちを叱責しなくちゃいけないという社会的なもうどうせもうそういうことでも
だからといって上にいて抑えるということは
これは人権侵害なんですね
だから なんで人間の中で
この人と喋る場合は 相手が納得するということ
ポイントは一番大事であると思わないんですかね
はい だから私たちはこの抑えられて生きているんですね
脅されて生きているんです
ああ 国会議員の先生が言うことだから
じゃあまあしょうがないとかね
総理大臣が言ったことだからしょうがないとかね
天皇陛下のお言葉だからしょうがないとかね
なんだこりゃと ローマ教皇様のお言葉だから
じゃあしょうがないとかね
例えばローマ教皇様であってもね
アホなことを言ったら
お前アホやと言わなくちゃあかんですよ
だってただの人間だから
最近何かの雑誌で読んだんですけど
このバチカンでね タバコを売ることは禁止したんだと
教皇が これは世界的なニュースとして流されるんですね
で まあいいことを言ってますよ
人間に害を与えるならば
それは合法的な儲けではありませんと
違法的な儲けで いわゆる神に逆らうことであると
タバコ吸ったらそれそんなのはものすごい昔からお釈迦様がおっしゃっているんですけど
商売をやる場合は一切の商売をやめなさいと
そうやられると馬鹿にされてるんですよ
酒麻薬を売るなよと 商売では武器
生命を殺すもの 武器と毒などなど売るなよと
それから生命売買するなよと
それだったらペットショップもダメですよ
まあ現代ペットショップはいくらか認められることだって
ペットは野生で生きたことは一度もないんだからね
人間が人工的に育ててるんだから
まあすぐ家出たら死にます
だったら大事に守らなくちゃいけない
まあそれだったらまあ金かかって育てて
まあそれでかわいく可愛がって買ってあげる人に売るっていうことは
まあまあ仕方がないんだけど
それでもやっぱり生命は生命だからね
自由がないなっていうこと
私は痛感 飼われている動物たちには自由がない
仏教ではやっぱり生命の商売禁止なんですね
だからヨーロッパにあったのは奴隷の商売
人間捕まって競りに出しておるという
えらい文化人ですね はい
そういうことで 私たちは一人一人で責任を持たなくちゃいけない
人が言ったことに自分で判断した
では 今 最近 ローマ教皇のあの発表はね
言葉は格好いいですと私も思いますね
人間に害を与えるならば
それは違法的な商売だと
それは私は仏教だからお前のことを信じませんではなくて
言った言葉自体が 納得いける
仏教の立場から見ても
一般人の考え方を見ても納得いける
はい そういうふうに 相手は誰であっても
自分自身が納得するならば
それでいいんです だから私を非難侮辱する必要はない
あなた仏教の坊主のくせに
なんでローマ教皇のことをそんなに褒めているんですか？とかね
しょうがないんですよ
言ってることにはちゃんと納得いける
何か意味があれば まあしょうがないですね
そういうことで この疑を
あるから私たちは調べて
自分自身で納得しようとする
だから疑ということが必要であります
では 仏教的な話に入ります
義と見解 これからちょっと難しくなります
知識があるとは 事実真理を知っているという意味ではありません
我々は知識ぶってますね
知識人やと仏教やけど
あのね 知識あるって言ったって
あなたは真理を知っているわけじゃないんだと
本当のことを知ってるわけじゃないんだと
事実を知識 知識なんです
エベレストを登頂したもう制覇した人の経験書いた本を読んで
どのように苦しかったとかね
どんなことがあったのかと読んで理解することはできますよ
だからといって 我々はその世界のこと何一つも知らないでしょうに
本読んだら知識はあります
それでちょっと英語でも書いてみたんだけど
英語でそれだけであまり書いてないだから怖がらないでください
knowledge is point of view. 知識とは一つのポイントオブビューなんですね
英語で書いたらこれ日本語できません
人はまずある見解 見方を作る
ポイントオブビューっていうのは見方ですね
知識っていうのは何か見方で達した結論なんです
だから我々はまず何か見解を持ってるんです
何か見方を持って作るんですね
持っているというと作るんですね
そのフォーマットに合わせてデータを調べて判断する
そこで別な見解で同じデータを調べると
別な判断 別な知識になります
それ私はよく私は仏教学やってましたから
だから仏教学でも百年
百年ぐらい昔から大学でやっているんですよ
で みんな論文を書くんですね
しかし 仏教というのは古いテキストを研究するでしょ
だから科学みたいに新しいもの現れることはないでしょ
なんで同じ経典テキストを参考していろんな論文を書けるんですかね
あれは見解なんですね
例えばパーリ経典から見れば
パーリ経典で見られるインド人の世界生活習慣についての研究で論文を書く
それでその人はパーリ聖典を全部片っ端から読んでます
日本だったら日本語で全部読めます
原本は原文で読まなきゃいけないんだけどね
それから論文を書く 論文にあるのは経典の内容じゃなくて
そこからちらちらと出てくるインド人の生活習慣だけです
私も一つ論文を書いたことがあって
あのブッダが語る政治論とは何という
だから先生たちに研究テーマを出されるたびに
初めから読解になるんですね
私は原文で読むんだけど
そこでまたサーッと経典がもう広げて広げていって
この政治家に対して 官吏に対して何語っているのかと
それだけピックアップして
論文を書いたんで それだけに膨大にテキストを調べなくちゃいけなくなっちゃったんだけど
ジャータカストーリー出たってもものすごい膨大だから
で それでお釈迦様のほか何もないんですね
もう一つ自分が書いた論文があって
この なぜブッダが無記という項目を設定したんですか？と
いわゆる答えない質問
これにはもう誰が研究したっても論文書けないんです
だけど 私もよくあの 大体人間には成長する時は誰か人間のモデルがあるんですよ
ですよ だからモデルを見て自分を育てていくんです
私もモデルにしたすごい優れた教授がいたんですね
ものすごい優れた人なんです
誰だってびっくりするんだよ
能力に で 彼が書いた これ
仏教でありながら哲学者の教授なんだよね
哲学 で 論文は一般の教授とあまり読まない
難しいというけど 私はもう何回も繰り返し繰り返し読むんですね
いつでもこの先生のガイドラインを使っていて
その先生も無記というポイントは使ってあって
で 結論には立てないんだと
こうではないか こうではないかということでね
そこで私がもう2  3週間ぐらいね
考えて考えて いろいろ調べてみると
まあ一応自分には答えが出たんだから
それは書いて出しちゃったんですね
教授たちは全部文句なく認めたんですね
私の論文がぴったし正しいと
それで私がずっと同じ経典を読んで
無記を無記って何なのかという角度で
あの尺度で あの色眼鏡で調べられてるんです
もう一度 政治論という色眼鏡で経典を読んだんです
そういう何かしらの色眼鏡を使わないと
もう大変なんです まあ今日は今回は経典を読んでなかったんだけど
今最近全然参考にしてないんです
年取っちゃったんだからね
疲れた で 例えば義についてと私は今日と読んだならば
義とは何やという色眼鏡をつけてテキストを読んでみる
これは世の中で知識世界でどうしてもあることなんです
ニュースの場合もあるんですね
私はよくニュースウィークを読みますから
この立派な記事書いてますけど
必ず自分で何かの色眼鏡をとって
それでデータを調べて書く
だからその通りだということにならないんですね
最近読んだのを覚えているのは
サウジアラビアの皇太子がね
はちゃめちゃなことをやっていると
まあ国をもう現代時代に合うように何か変えようとかね
まあはちゃめちゃな大胆なことをやってますけど
まあそこで本人が失敗したこととかね
あれやこれやと書いてあったりして
だからこの 新聞記事を書く場合でも
何か色眼鏡を使っているんです
そういうわけで 知識 知識っていうのは
何かしらの色眼鏡をかけてデータを調べたことなんです
科学も同じなんです 科学もなんでそれいろんな分科に分けているのかと
それぞれ自分で何かテーマを決めて研究していくんですね
テーマを決めたとは ある色眼鏡を取ったっていうことなんです
すごい子供のたとえ話で言えば
顕微鏡で見える世界 望遠鏡で見える世界といったら
それぞれ世界が違うでしょうね
それは結局知識になる
だから事実にはなりません
残念ですけど 知識は正解ではありません
知識 意見 見解はたくさん現れます
だから仏教も研究して研究いまもやっているんです
終わらないんです 毎年学生たちが何か論文を書く
まあほとんど大学の中でも死んでしまいますけど
大したことを書かないんだから
その中でも 100種類
200種類が論文で 一つ二つだけは人類の中で生き延びたりはする
これが最終な論文ということはあり得ないんですね
だからいつでも世の中で見解っていうのはあるわあるわあるわあるわ
いくらでも作られるんです
だから知識もいくらでも作られる
それで意見を作ったら
反対意見が無数に現れる
現れますから 正解として一つを選ぶことは不可能です
そういうわけで正解はない
ないからこそ そうではない
ああではないというふうに知識が現れてくるんです
だから世の中は未だに知識をありがたがっているし
未だに知識を応援しているし
どんどん知識人になれと言われているし
ということは 全く真理は知らないということになる
多数の意見 総合意見に達するのは難しいです
では 意見はたくさんある
日本国民は一人一人自分の意見を持っている
だから日本全体的にどうしようかと決めましょう
日本は国一つとしてどうしましょうか？では
国民一人一人に意見を聞いてみて
これ可能ですかね 論理的に
2つ可能ですね みんなの意見からカテゴライズして多数の意見を取る
でも多数の意見を取ったってもね
このカテゴライズシステムによってカンノリの意見捨てられているんです
その人とは意図的にバカ言ったわけじゃないでしょうね
真剣に語ったんだから
そんなのは無視してダメなんです
だからもうプラクティカル的にインポッシブルという
なんて言いますか もう使えないんですね
では総合意見作ろうかなと
作れるわけじゃないんです
それで私はこの見解を作って例出します
見解なければ先に喋れません
例えば 日本は一つの国として国際関係を持つべきかと
他の国のことを気にするべきかと
言っちゃうと 大体みんなやっぱり賛成するのが多いんですね
国際関係は無視できませんということになる
無視できませんと言っただけで答えじゃないんだからね
じゃあ どのように国際関係を持つべきですか？どのように関わるべきですかというと
その見解で見ると 意見が出るわ出るわ出るわ出るわ
もうキリがない もしかするとアメリカだけで友好関係で十分やという人いるかも
いや アメリカとヨーロッパだけの友好関係で十分やという人はいるかも
中国は敵国にしなくちゃいけないというかも
アジア アフリカは関係ないというかもね
いろんな意見出てきていきます
どんな意見出ても それはバカなことを言っているわけじゃなくて
自分なりの観察能力 だからどうやって総合意見作れるんですかね
面白い あれ 国民投票という現象がある
日本にもあるし どんな国でも一応あることはありますね
そうすると 国民の意見を聞くって問題二つしか出さない YES
かNOか 冗談じゃないと思いますけど
例えば イギリスがEUから離れるというね
あれ 単語まで作ったね BREXIT
というね そこでいろいろ議論ができたんだから
国民投票でYESかNOか
それだけ それで BREXIT は YES になっちゃったんだから
イギリスが大変ですよ
今は  EU から離れることってそう簡単じゃないんです
EU の国々は全然申請してくれないんです
お前らは初めからも態度でかかったということで
だから国民意見を聞くって言ったって
本当はインチキですよ
我々に色眼鏡をくれる
こちらにするかこちらにするかと
しかし それにも反対意見が成り立つので
正解にはなりません 例えば
総合意見を作っても 総合意見には反対意見が出てくるんです
はい 難しいんだから早く飛ばします
知識に達する手段 何か手段がなければ
これはちょっともう我々英語で考えちゃうんだから
この英語ではかっこいいフレーズでこの means of knowledge というんですね
で まあこれはまあ一般日本語にしちゃったんですね
知識に達する手段 こんな手段ですね
たくさんあります 両親
両親のおかげで知識に達したでしょ
両親に聞いてみる 両親の言葉を理解する
それを知識にする 師匠
有名人 有名人が言ったらすぐ乗る
皆様はハリウッドの有名人乗るかもしれませんだけど
普通はノーベル賞を取った人とか
ノーベル化学賞を取った人とかね
そういう人々の言葉を信じる
知識人 知識人の意見はどうせもうテレビ討論とかね
あるでしょ？知識人が集まっちゃって
何の役に立たないくだらないことを喋って
我々の時間はちゃめちゃ無駄に使って終わっちゃうんです
それから学歴 学歴ある人の話は認める
あの人東大卒業だからね
あの言った時点 その人のことを信じますよという話でしょ
私みたいなテロリストで
だから何ということはないんだから
誰も それから尊敬する人々
それから文化的な価値観
日本には日本の文化があって
日本文化的な価値観があって
中国には中国の文化があって
そちらに文化的な価値観がある
だからそれぞれ知識が変わるんです
なぜならば手段違いますから
だからヨーロッパ人の知識と我々アジア人の知識が違いますね
文化的な価値観が違うんだから
それから伝統 伝統だって言ったらすぐ乗っちゃいます
これは伝統だから それから宗教
宗教ということは 何の躊躇もなく信じるという知識にする
アメリカいるんですよ
いろいろ化石などなどは
あるいは神は人間を騙すためにいろんなところで置いておいたんだと
本当は神がまず人間を作って
それから動物を作っちゃったんだと
いう真面目な人々いるんです
それから信仰 宗教信仰変わったのは皆様のことを考えてなんですね
皆様にとっては宗教信仰必ずしも同じじゃないんです
で ヨーロッパでは同じになっちゃうんですね
アジアではこれ一つにならないんですね
宗教もある 信仰するものもまたある
ということはよくあります
それから聖書 聖書っていうのは
この神の言葉と言われるすべて
この場合はヴェーダ聖典
精神的にいかれた人が書いたコーラン
あれ読まないでください
頭がおかしくなります
で 旧約聖書 新約聖書 まあキリスト教の旧約聖書はいろいろ物語はあるんだけどね
あの物語はいかに屁理屈かと調べるとすごい楽しいんです
だからそれは読んでもそんなに頭がおかしくなりませんだけど
私はスリランカの大学にいた時は
キリスト教文化の教授がいたんですね
ノーベル博士ですごい頭のいい神父さんなんですね
私はこの人をいじめてやろうと思ったんですね
私はすごい年上ですよ
私はもう 20代あたりでしたからね
その時も教えてはいたんです
なぜいじめたいと決めたのは
私の授業にこそこそ顔を出すんですね
私は仏教哲学を教えているんだから
哲学の中でもいろいろ分野がありまして
ほとんど私はカバーしていたんですね
この人はそこそこと裏から
教室室に入っちゃう それで私はもうあまりにも年上の先生で
あの 我々ランク的にはものすごいトップで
私たちは管理する立場なんですね
いくら神父さんでも やっぱりその人がこうやって見ているとしゃべれなくなっちゃうんです
大体私は大胆で喋りますから
昔から あ 大学の決まり守らなくちゃとかね
仕切り守らなくちゃとか
何か私のトップにクレームしたら大変だとかね
いろいろ出てきて こちら微妙に緊張しちゃうんです
年上の方でもあるし ものすごい素晴らしい学者でもあるし
だから私が言って何か学ぶべき存在でしょうに
じゃあいじめると 思って
先生が ちょっと休んでいるところ
先生先生 何か質問してもいいんですか？と
いいですよ いいですよと
そしたら あのね 私は知っている知識では
キリスト教っていうのはキリスト様を教えてほしいですよと
そうでしょ？そうですよと
新約聖書ってのはキリスト様の言葉でしょうと
そうでしょうと でも先生たちがね
なんでキリスト様のお母さん信仰して拝んでるんですかと
お母さん関係ないでしょうに
なんでマリアを信仰しているんですか？と
先生にもぶら下がってでっかい十字架
マリア様もいたり これ何ですか？と
神様に直々おいでくださいと言ったら
しゃべるわ しゃべるわ
それはですね やっぱり人間
神様が真理と遠いんだから
あなた方でも何か言いたくなったらお母さんに言うでしょうとかね
だからお母さんには親しみやすいんだから
あれやそう言って 本人は自分には正しく私を納得させることはできなかったとわかったんです
私はかなり対立的な理論を持っていたと
本当に馬鹿にしたかったんですね
あんた方 聖書あるのに
マリアマリア様がおっしゃったこと何一つないんです
よく行ったんです だからクリスマスの場合は
まあ赤ちゃんだ マリア様
だからスリランカでカトリック教会いっぱいあるんで
どこでもなんだか聖母マリア
なんだか聖母マリア なんだか聖母マリアとかね
結局カトリックは聖母マリアだけでしょうと
あんた方はキリスト教じゃないんだと言った
これから来なかったんです
楽ちんで で そういうことでいろんな聖書の種類があって
この人にも私は聞いた
私は先生 こう言っても
私もキリスト教は徹底的に勉強したいんだから
聖書もう片っ端から読みたいと思いったら
カトリックバージョン聖書ありますか？と
イタリアカトリック教でそういう聖書バージョン作ってないんだと
なんでそんなのは一般人が素人が読んだら頭がおかしくなりますよと
そうですかと 私は言ったんだけど
その時に私はもしかすると５６回
読んでいるんです 第1ページから第終わりまで
でも私はニコッと笑う
やっぱり合ってましたね
ということは 真面目に読んだら頭からいかれるんだと
私はもう冗談考えながらいろいろ自分で納得するっていうことを昔からもあったんだから
自分で調べる 鵜呑みにしない
だからちょっと頭いかれていけないで守ったと思いますけど
皆様反対意見かもしれませんだけど
あんたとっくにいかれていると言うかもしれませんだけど
それはそれで意見だからね
はい それから占いなどの迷信
迷信 結構ありますね 占いの世界も結構ありますよ
日本人は自分たちの迷信
占い足らないんだから
全部輸入する 中国から昔輸入して
これはもう中国を馬鹿にする
すべて中国のものやっているのに
いい人間ですね それからヨーロッパから輸入して
自分の国は全部インドから輸入するんだけど
インドはあまり全体的にインドの能力を馬鹿にしようとはしません
ね で それから自分好みもあります
例えば自民党のメンバーがいるとしましょう
一般人で 議員でもなんでもなくて
その人が他の生徒が言う何喋ったって
なんだ あの人は何言ってるんですかねとか認めない
却下するんです なぜならば
自分好みの生徒があるんだから
だから自民党の先生方はどこかに講演なんかに行く場合は
まあプラカードを持って手を叩きながらもう大賛成してあげたりするんです
だから この自分好みで物事を見て正しいと決定する
それから感情も働くんですね
知識のために 怒り 嫉妬
憎しみなどなどのいっぱい感情がありましてね
感情で 例えば別れた人がいるとすると
自分が振っちゃったんですね
腹が立って その人は何やったっても間違いなんですね
仲良くしている時は同じことやっていたんだけど
その時はすごく良かったとかね
あなたのこれが気に入ったとかね
喧嘩して別れたら あんたこれだから私は嫌になっちゃったとか言うんです
だからもう知識っていうのは感情で変わるもんなんですよ
それから一部の人々は論理的に考える連中もいますね
論理が合っているならば
OK と 一部の人々はこの可能性
あ あり得る それはあり得る
例えば 例 トランプさんは弾劾されるかもと
裁判で訴えられちゃって
大統領さんが辞任しなくちゃいけない羽目になると
え？どういうこと？だって今こういう問題
こういう問題 こういう問題があってね
選挙運動はすごく違法でやったっていうね
違法のことで固まってたって
今証拠出ていますからね
それだったら 彼が合法的に大統領になったわけじゃない
だからもう弾劾される可能性あります
ああって そういえばそうだ
そうだと決めるかも これは私はパクった知識です
そういうふうに記事があったんです
弾劾される恐れがあると
で そういうことで この可能性によって
知識にする場合もあります
まだあります 大体全部一応まとめたつもりですけど
お釈迦様は 10項目説かれてありまして
人間の認識手段としてね
知識手段として この 10項目も捨てなさいと言っているんです
有名なカーラーの経典がありますね
もしかするとどこかどこかで私は使ったことがありましてね
あの 10項目は今日は言わないことにしましたけど
お釈迦様は 10番目に私は舎門で偉いと思ってね
鵜呑みにするなよということ
この沙門がとても尊い方だから
あんた言うことを信じるのやめなさいと
素晴らしいと思いますよ
先生が生徒にこう言う
私は先生だから言うことを鵜呑みにするなよと
自分たちが判断して納得しなさいと
調べる時 判断する時 以上の条件を使うんですね
誰だってここから抜けてはないんです
これは結局バイアス先入観ということになるんですね
お母さんこう言ったからと
一つのバイアスなんですね
いろいろお母さんにこれやるなよ
これやるな これやるなと言って
大人になった時は友達がこういうことをやりましょうと
やっぱりお母さんがやるなと言っていたんだから
私はやりませんと だから本人がお母さんというバイアスでやめているんですね
本当はそうじゃなくて
母親がお前もこう言っていることは正しいかなんか調べなさいと
調べて納得してやってくださいと言った方がいいのに
そこまで能力は人間にはないんですね
だから知識のために ノレッジのためにバイアスが必要です
それから個人の主観というまるっきり別なテーマになるんです
別なんです だから前ものをもうちょっと考え直しましょう
我々はいっぱい知識を持っています
その知識はあらゆるバイアスからいただいたもので
このバイアスがなければ知識にならないんです
母親から聞いた 先生から聞いたとかね
大学教授から聞いた 本で読んだとかね
それ個人の主観 個人 いくらなんでも自分の主観世界を持っているんですね
眼耳鼻舌身意で色声香味触法というデータを取り入れます
これは自分だけの世界なので
私の眼耳鼻舌身意がありますね
それで私がデータを入れているんです
皆様 皆様の眼耳鼻舌身意持っています
それで皆様自分でデータを取っている
自分というの知識を作ります
それデータを取って 自分というの知識を作ります
だから同じ我々 同じ環境にいますね
我々の眼耳鼻舌身意に同じものが入っているんですね
でも 一人一人が自分というの知識を作るんです
これは他の他人のデータ処理と同一になりません
このデータ処理する目に入るデータを頭
まあ頭の中で処理するんですね
合成するんですね 私と同じことをやるとはやりません
誰も 皆ね 自分の意見というものがあるんです
ないとは言いませんよ
私はそう何の意見もないんだと
ないんです 眼耳鼻舌身あれば
あんたこの肉体で認識しているでしょうに
それはあなたの考えです
あなたが合成した世界です
ないはずがない で ちょっと脱線してしております
お釈迦様の時代で 仏典では六師外道という 6人のことを書いているんです
仏教でこの口癖で六師外道と言うんだけど
まあそれなりの有名人でしたから
お釈迦様より年上なんですね
その 6人の中で一人の宗教は未だにインドにものすごい派手にあるんです
6番目の方の教えは  5人の教えは消えちゃったんだけど
仏教はインドにないんです
そこでその中で一人が
認識否定する哲学を言い出しちゃったんですね
いわゆる知識的な答え出しません
で 仏教的にはその人はバカにするんですね
どういうことかというと
人殺すは人殺すこと 悪いですね
先生 まあ私は悪いとも思わないし
良いとも思わないし 五分五分だと思えないし
まあ何も思えない 何も言いませんね
じゃあ人殺すこといいことですかねと
いいとも思いませんし
悪いとも思いませんとかね
何を聞いても本人がこの偏見ではなく
先入観を持ってないような振る舞っちゃうんですね
でもさ バカやとお前は
曖昧な態度を取ろうと思ったでしょうにと
それはその人の世界でしょうに
だから仏教の批判する時は脳みそ何か鳴ってるんだと
だからこの意見持ったら別な意見がありますね
自分の意見を発表すれば
反対する人々は反論する
そうすると自分がそれを弁解しなくちゃいけない
能力ないでしょうと あんたには
だから意見持たないふりをする
あるいは脳が壊れちゃって
何が何だかわからない状態でいる
あれは無知そのもの どん底
だからこの花が綺麗ですが
わからない このバカが
綺麗ってどういうことか
花ってどういうことかとか
あまりにもわからない
そういういくつかの理由であると
だから本当は僕たちは眼耳鼻舌身持っているならば
そちらには主観があるんです
ないわけじゃないんです
だからその人ははっきりした意見を持たないことにしましょうと意見を持ってるんです
というわけで 仏教的にはそれは矛盾ですね
自分の見解が他人の見解と似ているか
同じか違うのですか？という問題は常に存在します
そこで私は私の主観を持っていますけど
この主観 他人の主観と合っていますか？同じですか？違いますかと
常に疑問があるんです
しかし しょうがないんですね
これは理解してください
私は私に見える 聞こえる
感じる世界を認識している
だから他人が他人に見える
聞こえる 感じる世界があります
似ているかも 似ていないかも
全く反対かも そこで止めればすごく楽なんですよ
人と喧嘩しないで あんたがおかしいと言ったらおかしいんです
あんたがおかしくないんです
これは自分の主観を持って
あの相手をぶん殴ろうとしただけの話なんです
自分の意見で はい それから偽の世界が現れますね
六根に対してデータを合成して知る
知識にする それは確かな判断でも正解でもないので
だって自分の脳みそが処理することだから
これこそ正しいとないでしょう
常に心の中に疑いがあるんです
常に疑いがあるんです
何か自分が食べていて
これは結構美味しいなと思っていて
同じものを友達も取って食べて
ああ ね これはちょっと味が良くない
言った途端自分が不安になっちゃうんです
なんだこれ もうもう良くないと言われちゃう
自分が本当美味しいと思ってたのに
だから自分の主観 他人の主観
そうやってぶつかると疑いが作っと
現れて いつでも毎日 24時間起きてるんです
それで我々は仕事をして
いろんな仕事をして まあ他人が来て認めるだろうと期待しているでしょ
もし認めてくれなかったらがっかりするんですね
何ですかね 自分が自分の主観
例えば家をきれいに 今日は腕を振ってきれいに掃除しますと
ピッカピカになるようにする
そうすると 家の人々入ってきたら
ああ 今日はすごい綺麗になっているんだと認めて欲しがるんですね
びっくりして欲しがるんです
あ びっくり すごい綺麗になっていると
そう言われてくれたら楽しいんです
なぜならば 自分の主観にあったんですね
しかし 入った人は気づかなかったら
その人は自分の世界の場合はがっかりしちゃうんですね
これは人間の生き方なんです
ですから 常に心の中に疑いがあるんです
あるいは奥さんが綺麗にピカピカしたつもりでいたんだけど
旦那さんが何か調べてると
ここら辺本当にすごい汚れてるんだからと言った途端
あの自分の心の疑いが生まれてくる
俗世間でいう疑 疑い深いは
ただ人が他人の意見を信じないだけの話です
これ 皆様の世間で 我々の世間でも
あの人疑い深いやとかね
私は信じませんけど 偉そうなこと
あんな程度じゃないんです
あれは人を信じないだけのことなんです
大したことないんです
人を信じないだけで これは自分がすごいしっかりしているイメージでもないんです
仏教道義がもっとすごい深いもので
この疑疑比設信で主観を作っているんだから
問題は みんな生命は自分の疑疑比設信持っているんです
だから我々はお互い違うんですね
違うんだから 相手の意見と私の意見というのはどうかよくわからない
そこで疑というものは常にあるはずなんです
で これは普通いう 最初に言ったこのラショナルダウト
理性的な疑とももうちょっと違うんですね
もっと存在の根本的な問題なんです
生きるとは認識し続けることでもあります
認識は必ず疑を作ります
生きるということはもう感じることでしょう
いわゆる認識することです
だったら疑があるんです
疑は心に基本的にあるものです
主義 この疑に対して致命的な問題もあります
ブッダにも助けることが不可能な問題があります
私たちは自分の見解 意見を好きです
だって他の見解ないでしょ
私には私の主観しかないんです
私はそれが好きです 他の意見
反対意見が現れない時は
見解は正見正見正解だと決める
自分の主観 誰も攻撃していない場合は
俺は正解だと 俺は正しいとと思っちゃうんです
我は正しいと思っちゃうんです
自分の意見 見解 思考が観念に執着すると
改良 訂正は不可能です
我は正しいと思ったらアウト
終わり 疑があった方がいいんです
私はこのご飯がおいしいと思うんだけどねと
そうすると友達があのね
これはまずいんだよと
そう それで何か勉強できます
なんでまずいというの？とかね
で なんであんたおいしいというの？とかね
そこで何か話し合って
自分の主観をいくらか改良することはできます
俺は正しいんだったらアウト
自分の意見に愛着を持ったら
その人は育てません その人は終わりです
ブッダにさえ救うことはできません
皆様の手元にある日常読経なんてテキストは
そちらの サンレイカスッタという経典があります
それ 44 ぐらいの項目があります
それは大体道徳の戒律的な道徳的な経典ですけど
そちらで人間の悪いところは 44 項目に書いてあるんだけど
最後に一番悪いものと書いてあるのは
自分の意見にしがみすぎて離れないことです
改良する気持ちがなく
離れない 執着していること
それが悪の中で最大の最低の悪なんです
だから嘘を言ったとか
人を喧嘩した 喧嘩したとかね
そんなに大げさな罪じゃないんです
だってアンゴリマーラのエピソード知ってるでしょ？アンゴリマーラという人が大量殺人なんです
お釈迦様出家させたんです
悟ったんです 今までも900人以上人殺して
あんたはと 本当に殺人鬼ですよ
なぜ悟ったのかと あの最後の項目なかったんです
あの人 すごい知識人で学者なんです
だから我こそ正しいじゃなくて
新たな知識 誰か教えてくれるならば教えてくださいという
それだけやったんです
44の中で 1個だけ守っていたんです
最後のもの それで悟ったんです
他の罪はなんとか なんとかもう改良することはできます
これは自分一人の問題だからできないんですね
成長は止まります はい
次 今 私は義があると説明しました
我々みんなに あの理性的な疑いは簡単に育ててください
それはそんな大きなもので
ヨーロッパでも言っていることだからね
ラショナルダウトということがね
これは我々よく知っていますね
調べるべきだと でも怠け者が調べたくないんですね
テレビニュースに頼りたいんですね
ネットの情報に頼りたいでしょ
あれはあてにならないんだけどね
私たちは言に必慎に頼っている限り
義があるということ 義が現れるということ
義が根本的であることに気づかなくちゃいけないんです
だから義に気づくことが大事です
義が働く心は不安なので
皆義がないように振る舞う
なんかどうしよう どうしようとかね
よくわからないもうどこ
なんか不安でしょ すごく不安なの
だからなんか義がないように
義を否定する人は何でもうなみにする
だから人 人が言ったことにすぐ飲んで乗ってしまうんですね
だから自分に義 義があることを認めないんです
ごまかすんです 他人の立場
知識などを権威にする
だってあの人こう言ったんだからね
NHK のニュースで流れたんだからね
いうことで 何か権威をつけて
あの人 この研究はね  5 年間も研究したんだからね
その人の意見だよと そういう意見も毎日 NHK で放送してるでしょ
全部嘘でしょ 私はこれ冗談で考えると
なんとか分野でまあ 20年研究した教授がなんだらかんだら大学から出たんですかと
私はお前生まれた小学校の時からその研究したのかい？と聞きたくなるんです
歳もないのに 人を騙すためにそういう風に言う
だから 10年も研究したならばね
まあ研究を始めて何年ですかね
で でも言っていることはろくなことじゃないんですね
結局は だからこの権威使うというね
だって私たちも本を買う場合はね
タイトル読んで気に入った途端何する？後ろ見るんですね
書いた人の経歴を読んでみる
その権威で本を買わせたりする
それは義があるからなんです
タイトル気に入っただけで買っているわけじゃないんですね
義があるんです だから本当にこれ役に立つ本
信頼できる本でしょうかと
この書いた人の著者の経歴で自分が判断する
それも主観の判断なんです
だから すごい肩書きのある信頼できる人でも
くだらないものを書かないという保証はないんだけどね
他人の意見を攻撃して自分の意見を弁解する
義に気づいてないんです
だから自分に義があるということは知らないバカが人の意見に攻撃するんです
自分が正しなければ攻撃できんでしょ
自分の意見 なんで弁解するんですかね
自分が正しいと思っているからでしょ
それで頭が固くなる 堕落する
無知のままでいることになるんです
だから義を義に気づきましょう
私には義があると 正解知らないんだと
ダンマパダにね お釈迦様がおっしゃった言葉がありまして
今日書いてないんだけど
たとえ愚か者であろうとも
自分が愚か者であると知っているならば
賢者になりますと 愚か者のくせに自分が知っていると思うならば
その人は愚か者のままで終わりますよと
バーローチャ・パンディタマーニ セーウェー バーローティ ブッジャティ
だからあれ これ義についてお釈迦様が扱ったところなんですね
だから我はあまり知らないという態度が素晴らしいんです
いろいろ知っているように頭はでっかちで頭の中でいっぱい溜まってるんだけど
いつでも義があるんだよと
だからみんななんで気づかない？例えばある神社に行って子宝に恵まれますようにと
もう何かお札を買ったりね
その場合は 1,000円ぐらいになりますけど
もう何か買ったりして
もうお守りを持って帰る
あのね それもらったら
あんた本当にあなたに子供が授かる？本当に？聞いちゃうと怒られるでしょ
怒る必要ないんです やっぱり義があるんですよ
そちらにも それが 100%確かだと
ある神社のお札を買ってきたら
誰だって子供が子供に授かると思ったら 100%
確実だ 確実だったら義がないでしょう
そうすると 男である私も行ってお札を買ってきたら
まあ子供が生まれるということもあり得る
だから義がないものはないんですよ
それに気づけば うん 次に行きます
不安にならず 義を使う
まず言ったのは もう義があると
もうすっごく不安なんですね
判断できなくなると だから義を忘れるという間違った手段をとるんです
でも お釈迦様がいえ 正しく義を使いましょうと
義は事実だから 義を通して真理に達する方法ですね
知識 手段を確認する まず
自分の知識は正しいと確定しないで
ちょっと逃げ道を探ってください
正しいと確定すると潰されます
私の知識はまるまるさんから聞いた話だと
そうすると物の見方が逃げられるでしょ
お前ばかよと言わないでしょ
私の私はこのように信じている
これは私の一応信じているんだけど
私の好みの意見だ  いうふうに言えばいいんです
これは伝統的な考え方だ
それで身を守られます
お前バカじゃないか アホじゃないかということは言われなくなります
皆の意見だなどを強調してください
これから  これは皆の意見だ
こういうふうに生きてみてください
これはこういうことですと
これは正しいですと言うと
やめて 私は正しいと思うんだけど
あの思うんだけどって
あれを入れてください
どちら選ぼうというならば
どちらかというと 私はこちら選びましょうと
で これは正しいというふうに飛ばないでください
要するに正しいという言葉を下げてください
認識に達した手段をちゃんと出してください
その人は真理を知らなくても真理を守る人間です
まだまだ真理を知らないんだけど
真理を守っているんです
その人には自分の意見を変えることができるんです
真理に達することができるんです
見解を正す柔軟性が現れるのです
例えばこういう意見 私はまるまるさんのね
話を聞いて こういうことだと思ってますよと言ったら
友達があのね 私はこの間
まるまるさんのね 師匠に会いましたけどね
その師匠がね こいつはもう本当にいい加減なことを言っていると言いましたから
ああ そうですかと それで自分が
じゃあまるまるさんの意見は受け取るよりは
師匠の考えも考え聞いてみようという気持ちになっているんです
だから その時点で自分の知識レベルがちょこっと上がる可能性が現れたんです
これ確かと決めを決定すると終わりなんですね
だから安倍さん言うことばっかり
安倍さんだから総理だから正しいではなくて
野党側もいい話も聞いてみると
いう感じになった方がいいとは思います
それから問題は知識見解から解放できない
私はいつでもずっと悪口言ってきたでしょ
もう全部もう見解で色眼鏡で知識になっているんだと
でもこれから 開封できませんよ
学問研究できんだから
色眼鏡かけないと 大学で嘘を言ってますよ
自由な研究 客観的な研究
科学的な研究 嘘ばっかりで
そんなありえないんです
まず色眼鏡作るんですよ
研究に入る前に自分たちが仮説を作ってるんです
それは研究のやり方なんです
だから なかなかこの見解
世界 知識 世界からは逃げられません
俗世間で生きる限り 意見
見解 主観 知識に頼らなくてはならない
これnecessary evilですね
見解は正解ではないと認める
どうしても私は見解で生きているんだけど
それは正解ではないんだと
自分の意見を常に訂正可能な状態にします
だから常に訂正しまくってください
自分の知識は常にペンギン保留であって
confirmed 確定ではないんです
これは仏教お釈迦様が皆様に提案する別な生き方なんです
いくら知識あってもいいんです
すべてペンギンにしてほしい
confirmed しないんです
確定にはしないんです
自分が偏見持ってます
色眼鏡持ってます しょうがないんです
そうでなきゃ生きていられません
それを認めるだけ 正しいとは言わない necessary
evil です necessary
evil って日本語で何て言いますか？必要悪
必要悪です それから これは成長の機動力にするんです
義がある人は学ぶ 議論
対話する しかし論争はしない
議論と対話と論争って違うでしょ
論争の場合は自分を弁解するんですね
相手を倒すんですね 他人の意見にも耳を傾ける
理解する 相手の意見を理解したからって
それは信じる必要ないんです
相手はどのように考えてこの理解に達しているのかと
例えばテロリストがいる
我々はテロリストは反対ですけどね
テロ行為は当然反対 でもテロリストに会うことができたら
話をやってみてください
相手を直す必要ないんです
どういう考えで どういう判断で
どういう価値観で そういう活動をしているのかと
なるほどなるほどと理解してあげてください
しかし 認める必要はないんです
そうすると テロリストが自分の友達になりますけどね
これ論争しちゃうと けしからん
そんなのはと もう先に自分を殺されるかもしれませんね
だから 誰の意見でも理解してあげてください
惜しみなく自分の間違いを直す
それから 自分には考えの間違いがあったとわかったら
あーよかったかと直せばいいんです
あ 恥ずかしい これはと思っちゃうと
自我で義を認めてないんです
間違っていることは恥ずかしくないんだ
当たり前です だって見解で生きているんだから
だから間違いを見つけることは楽しい
間違いを教えてくれる人いればありがたくてしょうがないと
これは仏教の道徳の一つなんです
我々はものすごく気遣わなくちゃいけない道徳の一つなんです
皆様方 思っている戒律と本物の戒律は違うんです
だから我々はこのサンガでこのサンガ儀式やりますよ
サンガ儀式の場合は 私が知っている
知らない 気づかなかった
進行員の何が間違いだったらどうかお願いしますから教えてください
ぜひ直してみますというふうに自分を投げ出すんです
これは道徳 戒律なんです
だから間違いっていうのはどうったことない
当然みんな間違ってますから
だからそれは仏教はポジティブ思考で使う
あの人 私の間違いを教えてくれてありがとうございます
ありがとうございます
本当に専修ですと その代わりに人間どう出ますか？どうですかね
間違いを教えたら腹が立って興奮しちゃって
もう殺しに来るんですね
なんであなたは何様のつもりですか？と
これは仏教徒はやめるんです
子供でも間違いを教えてくれたら
ありがとうございます
あんた賢いですねと その通りにやりますと
そういう性格を直してください
謙虚で知識を与える人に敬意を持つ
だから知識は完全じゃないんだけど
まあいいんです 何か教えてくれる人がいれば
その人に敬意を持ってください
これも仏教の道徳一つなんです
学ぶ人 学生が教えてくれる人に心の中で敬意を持たないと
知識は入らないんです
だからお釈迦様はどれほど脳科学が進んでいたかったよ
全部漏れちゃうんです
年下であっても教えて何か知ってるものはいっぱいあるんだから
だから私はいろいろパソコンのことになってくると
子供たちに聞くんです
ある程度自分知ってるんだけど
やっぱりガキたちが上手ですからね
さっさとそいつらもう私には 30 分かかる作業はだいたい 10 分以内でやってくれる
で 私は何のことなく えっ
お前偉いねとかね 俺だったらこれえらい時間かかりますよとか
で それが正しい道徳的な生き方なんです
はい それで義の機動力
義がすごい機動力 パワーなんです
義があれば 自分 自分が自分の義に気づけば
世界誰でも先生になるんです
世界の誰からでも何か学ぶものあるんです
だから義はありがたいんですよ
先生探してハチャメチャ苦労する必要ないんです
いつでも誰でも先生になれる
誰からでも何か学ぶものはある
自分の意見に執着しない人には
誰からでも学ぶことができます
我は正しいと決定しない人にとっては
誰からでも学べる 他人に教えることもできるので
良い先生にもなります
だから世の中にいる先生たちがものすごい下手でしょう
だから自分が知らないと
自分には義があるんだと知っている人が教える時はその立場で教えるんです
私が知っている範囲はこれぐらいですけどとかね
まああなたも考えてくださいとかね
間違っている可能性もありますよとかね
そういうふうに教えるならば立派な先生ですよ
だから義はすごい機動力を持っているんですよ
社会で調和を保って平和で生きられる
その人には社会と対立する必要はないんです
どこへ行っても仲良く生活できる
人格が向上します それは義
義 義はいかにありがたいかという説明ですね
それから自ら判断しなさいという言葉があるんですね
自ら判断しなさいと釈尊も教えていますが
中正をこの中正じゃないね
まあまあいい  大丈夫です
この字で大丈夫です  正しいと正しい単語を私は使いますけどね
まあ中正でいいんですを保たなくてはならないんです
でお釈迦様おっしゃったんだけど
自ら判断し カーラム経典でバラモンたちに自ら判断しなさいと
こんな言いやすいんだけど
やりやすくはないんです
だって自分がこんな能力でどう判断するんですかね
義を持って様々なデータを調べるんです
だから判断の仕方というのは
義を持ってデータを調べる
客観的に自分の能力のあった判断します
何か判断しますよ でもそれは正しいわけじゃなくて
今せいぜい私にできるのはこの程度の判断ですと
私が調べたところ 私にはこういうふうに結論に達することができました
これは私の精一杯 力いっぱいですと言えばいいんです
決めること 判断すること
最終的に自分自身判断
自分自身の判断であるという事実を実感してほしい
ちょっと脳が抜けてますね
自分自身の判断 そこで自ら判断というのは
データを調べて 自分で理解できる範囲で感情を抜きにして客観的に判断する
しかし 責任持ってほしい
これが私が達した判断ですと
これで自分で責任を持つということになってくると
どんどん成長はするんです
弁解しない だってしょうがないでしょうとか
すごく違うんですよ 例えば人を怒鳴ったとする
だってしょうがないでしょ
そんなこと言うんだから
その人は無知です だってしょうがないでしょうはないんです
あなたは正しいわけじゃないんです
あなたは主観を持っている
あなたは自分という偏見で見ている
そこで客観的にデータ
あなたなりに判断したところで
あなたが怒鳴るべきだと判断しまった
それは怒鳴ったことは正解か不正か
これは知らない だから私は怒鳴った方がいいと思ったんだけどね
私が判断しましたよ 責任持ってください
弁解やめてください 弁解する人は仏道じゃなくて
智慧の世界じゃなくて
地獄の道へ進んでいるんです
だってそうでしょうはないんです
それはありえないんです
だから自分がした判断
責任持つ それは客観的にデータで間違っているとわかったら
あ 間違ってしまったと喜んで訂正する
もう一回やりませんよと
だから自分の間違いを見たらすごく喜んで
それ直す あの明るさと次これ
次最後だと思います 知識から真理を発見する智慧
真理発見したら知識いらなくなっちゃいます
この偏見なゴミ 全部捨てられます
私はいつでも言う たとえが地球が丸いということ
もう意見いらないね もう真理発見してるんだから
一切の主観 感情 先入観が消えたところで
知識ではなく智慧が現れます
だから仏教では八正道でしょう
仏道っていうのは正見から始めるんです
まず智慧の定義 真理を知る
発見する能力は智慧です
だから知識の能力ではないんです
知識というのは 色眼鏡があってデータを調べること
それは知識 智慧っていうのは真理を発見する
意見見解ではなく 正見
正解を発見する力は智慧と言います
義があるからこそ はい
これからプログラム書きます
皆様にも義があるからこそこちらに来たんです
義があるからこそ ブッダの教えを学んで理解する
俺は知ってるという気持ちだったら来ないでしょ
理性に合っているか否かを自分で判断する
ブッダの教えであっても
経典に書かれているものであっても
理性的か 理性に合っている
何か間違いではないんですかと
そうやって調べてほしいんです
間違たりません で あ やっぱり理性に合っている
この通りじゃ 色になりませんとわかったら
では試してみよう では試してみよう
で 影響を引き起こす それからお釈迦様が人類初めて智慧に達するのを教えたんです
それは観察しましょうと
似ているものを科学世界でもあります
学問の世界でもあります
観察すると あるんだけど
みんな色眼鏡を持っているんです
微生物を研究するという色眼鏡を持ったら
微生物ばっかり探している
そうすると この人々は顕微鏡の世界に閉じ込まれます
望遠の世界とはさようならです
だから観察しましょう
顕微鏡で微生物を でも
天然ながら色眼鏡を持っている
お釈迦様が色眼鏡を外して観察することを人類初めて説かれたんですね
先入観を破ることは時間がかかる作業で
だから知識っていうのは先入観ですよ
すべての知識 気づきの実践は心を固定概念
先入観から本当は徐々に解放します
だから仏教では自分の存在をそのまま観察しなさいと
そのまま歩くことやら座ることやら
体の膨らみ縮みやら痛みかゆみやら
そのまま何も考えません
色眼鏡つけません かゆみ
あ かゆみは嫌と言ったら
もう判断しているんです
主観で見ているんです
かゆみとかゆみを研究してみる
色眼鏡ない ありのままの現象が
そこをやっていると なんとなく心から先入観
固定概念 宗教的な観念
全部なくなっちゃって
なんとなく自分でありのままに見えてくる
その時 お釈迦様さえすらいらなくなっちゃいます
最終的に一切の現象は無常苦無我であると発見します
これってただの現象だと
だから眼耳鼻舌身で主観を作っているでしょ
目に入るデータは常に無常で
だったら頭の中で変わらない現象は現れるはずがないんだと
だったら見解は立てられないでしょうにと
知識は成り立たないでしょうにと発見していくんです
人間の知識見解とはすべて偏見であることを理解します
だから自分の知識すべて偏見であったとわかった途端
生命の知識も偏見であるとわかるでしょう
成り立たない 無常だから
私は見た見た見たと言ったって
写真撮って固定しようと思ったって
そんなのはあり得ないんです
自分の写真撮ってみてください
撮った瞬間から自分と写っているんです
違う自分なんです だから最初これは私でしたと言えませんよ
私は自分の写真を見て一度も私と思ったことないんです
思ったことないんです
ああ こいつは若かったねとかね
一切の見解に対する愛着が消えます
まだまだ見解あるかもよ
怒るんだから 視線が遅くだからね
でも愛着がない そこで疑いが消えます
執着に値する見解はありません
執着するべき見解は一切ないんだと
皆さんは私のような すごく自由に神様を馬鹿にすることはできます
馬鹿にすることは私の見解じゃないので
私はただ冗談を言っているだけです
その見解に執着してないんです
成り立たないことが成り立っていると勘違いしているんだと知っているだけなんです
だから 執着するべき見解
固定概念はありません
無常です 真理を発見するので疑いが消える
これが真理です これで初めて心から疑いが消えるんです
疑いが消えると同時に
知識もあの重役からちょっと
置いておきます 重役の座からちょっと抜けます
まだ体があるんだから知識が必要ですよ
例えば悟ったからといってね
電車に乗る場合 その方法を理解しないとね
その知識消えるわけじゃないんだけど
重役ではないんです それで生きているということじゃないんです
すべての生命にある不安
悩み 落ち着かないこと
精神的な曖昧が消えます
それで初めてすべて曖昧が消えちゃって
落ち着いて不安が消えるんです
不安というのは この認識から生まれるんです
疑いが消えるとは 預流果の悟りに達したことになります
いわゆる曖昧が消えたと
それのは因果法則を理解するか
無常空無が理解するかどちらかなんで
それは自分を観察するとわかるんですね
そういうことで 義をありがたく使って
知識世界でもうまく生きてみて
人と喧嘩しない 論争しない
しかし議論する 誰からでも教えてもらう
間違いを教えてくれる人には人を尊敬する
相手が子供であっても
それで生きてる場合は調和と持って平和で生きていられる
さらにブッダの教え 義を持って勉強して
義から解放するという真理を開けるというプログラムです
話は以上です どうもありがとうございます
はい スマナサーラ先生
ありがとうございます
講演今で今のスライドで一応終了なんですが
あと 50 分ぐらい時間ございます
たっぷり時間ございますので
今日の講演に関すること
あるいはそこから連想したことなど何でもいいんですけど
ご質問のある方いらっしゃいましたら
挙手していただきましたら
今マイク回します 最初の
今日はどうもありがとうございました
えーと ちょっと子供のことで悩んでいることがあります
まあ盗みをしたりとか
嘘をついたりとかをするんですが
私としてはそれを子供をそのように疑ったことはなかったんですが
まああの まあ客観的に見て
本当にお金を取っていたりとか
あの まあ私にも嘘をついて
まあ結局バレていたり
バレてしまったりとか
そういうことが最近目立つようになってきました
中学1年生の男の子ですけれども
で 結局私は子供のことを疑わないで見過ごしてきてしまった部分が
子育ての中で多かったのかもしれませんけれども
今日もここに来るときに
まあちょっと怒ってしまったというか
彼を あのもう嘘をつくことと盗むことはいけないということを言って
まあ放置して出てきてきてしまったっていう感じなんですけれども
今度から彼のことを疑おうかなって自分の中では思ってしまったわけなんですね
で その疑うっていうことに関して
今日の ちょうどのお話は
私にとってちょっと刺々しいところがあったんですが
その子供に関して  はいはい
同僚 同僚とかに当てはめると
あ 確かにそうだなって
会社のこととかは思い当たる節はありますか？本当に自分の子供に関して
どうやって接して そこら辺を正してしていくっていうか
それも私の偏見なのかもしれませんけれども
どういう風に付き合っていて
ただ 真っ当な人間といいますか
誰にも間違いはあるとは思うんですけれども
はい ここで話を止めてください
はい あなたに何も判断できなくて
活動動けなくなっているでしょうに
だから喋っても喋っても質問にはいかない
結論にはいかない もうわかってるんだから
何聞いてるのかと はい
まあそれで この世間の考えでしょう？子供のことだけは疑うなよとかね
いい加減にしろよ 世間が真実言ってるわけじゃないでしょうに
子供に殺される親もいるでしょうに
子供だからといってただの人間でしょうに
人間って嘘つきに決まってるんだから
別に子供のことを疑ったってどうったことない
それで悪い母親になるわけじゃないんです
小さい時からもそういう気持ちをするならば
ちっちゃい時 いろんなちっちゃい時もやってますよ
お母さん騙すこと その時は可愛い可愛いで騙されたなとかね
あなたにとかね その時なんで言わなかったんですかね
だからじわじわとあなたのこともあなたを騙すことをやってきて
あなたにバレないし バレたってもあんたアホでしょうし
だからあいつは大きくなってくると大胆にやろうと思っているんです
その女を簡単に騙されると
この態度変えてください
はっきり言ってください
あなたを信頼してきたんだけど
信頼はきれいになくなりましたと
あなたのことを心配するのはこの世の中で母は第一ですよと
あなたははその人の信頼を失うことをしましたと
あなたの友達があなたを助けてくれると思っているんですかと
それでよければ どうぞ自由に頑張ってください
それからあなたのことを信頼しませんと
金は全く盗めないように私は隠しておきますと
あなたは自由ですと 他人ですという風な厳しい言葉言っても構いませんよ
あるいは なんであなたを徹底的に信頼して愛しているか
心配している母親に 物事を言ってくれないのか
あんた まだまだ世の中わからないでしょ？だから私に何でも言ってみなさいよ
怒ったっても気にすることじゃないんだ
だって母親だから だからそういうケースを作るのは
結局母親のこともそれほど信頼していないんですね
だから言ったらまずいんだから
言わないで何か やったりするんですね
そういうことで疑って
新たな信頼関係を作ってみてください
人は毎日変わるんだから
あなたは毎日変わらなくちゃいけないんです
子供の成長はかなりスピーディスピーディだからね
これは仕方がない 母親もそのスピードに自分の生き方変えなくちゃいけないです
1日で子供が変わるんですよ
そういうことですよ まあ一応信頼を失ったということでね
子供をちょっと 不安に陥れて
やばいという気持ちにさせて
それから正しく生きる方法わかるようにしてあげてください
はい 以上です ...本日は貴重なもの
大いにありがとうございました
執着というものを除くのに
やはり座禅という瞑想方法はとても有効ではないかと思うのですけれども
その同じ姿をしている座禅であるにも関わらず
例えば日本仏教ですと
只管ただという曹洞宗の座禅
そして臨済宗で取られていると言われているカンナ禅というものがありまして
かなり心の中のアプローチというものがかなり異なるような気がいたしまして
そしてそれともヴィパッサナー瞑想における禅座禅は
またその両者ともかなり異なるように感じております
で まあ駒澤大学で長くおられたということで聞いておりますので
もしテーラワーダ仏教の立場から見たら
曹洞宗の座禅はどのように見えるのか
あるいはもしご存知であれば
臨済宗のカンナ禅という手法がどのように見えるのか
そこら辺をちょっともしできればお聞きしたいと思いまして
質問させていただきました
これは単純なもう一つ新しい知識をくださいというね
質問ですけどね 知識っていつだって偏見でね
どうってことないと思いますけどね
正しい答えはね 先入観から心を解放する観察方法なんです
観察しなきゃ知識も知恵も何も現れませんね
観察するときは科学的
世間の観察では色眼鏡を使って観察をする
ブッダは色眼鏡を外して観察する方法を教えている
それで我が消えて見解いなくなって
知恵が現れて悟りに達するっていうプログラムなんですね
悟りに達するというのは仏教の偏見ではないかと
理論は成り立ちます しかし
悟りとは生きる苦しみをなくすことだから
生きる苦しみをなくすことはすべての生命の課題なんです
悩み 苦しみなく安穏な達したいということは
すべての生命の希望なんです
人間も動物も神々もみんな
だからしょうがないんです
これは仏教の偏見ではないんですね
そういうわけで 知恵を開発するために
先入観なく観察しなくちゃいけないんですね
私は人の見解には悪口言いませんし
そのまま理解するだけで
だから私の意見を聞いたっても
何言うか私もわからない
私も偏見を持たないと何も喋れなくなっちゃうんだからね
うん 例えば しかんたさの場合は
しかんたさという言葉自体は正しいんです
ただいるだけのことだからね
ということは 知識はない
思考はない 心は揺らがない
心は安穏状態にある 言葉正しいんだけど
この連中はバカみたく座ってるだけ
お前ら何やってるのかと
アホじゃないかと 私は逆に偏見を持って批判する
私はそうする坊さんたちに
あのね しかんたさっていうのは悟りやと
解脱やと勘違いしないでくださいと
ただ足を組んで四十分寝ただけで
それは悟りでもなんでもないんだと
しかんたさに達しなさいよと
という批判は言える いつでも言うわけじゃないんです
批判するためには自分が何か偏見を持たないと
それで 臨済宗の場合はもうカンタとなんたらかんたら言ってね
いわゆる何か公案みたいなものを使っているんですね
公案っていうのはすごい面白いんです
臨済宗の方々にできないんだけど
中国文化にあるすべての公案を私に解決することはできます
私にとっていたって簡単です
ただ 答えが言葉にならないケースは結構ありますけど
で 公案というものがね
真理を文学的に人間の理屈にはめない
人間の思考には決してはめない
別な次元で言葉並んでいるんですね
だから そのフレーズを作るためには
作った師匠がそれなりの精神的に育っ優れていないとできないんです
それは私は否定しませんよ
しかし 頭はちゃめちゃ苦労させて公案の答えを考えたって
お前考えてるだけやと
何にもならんやという批判もできます
そこで先生たちも答えの本を持ってるんですよ
生徒がその答えを言ったら OK にするんですね
まだ悟ってないんですね
また次の公案だ 次の公案だ
どこまで出すのかと 結局は頭がある理論
論理構成作っちゃって言ったらすぐ答え出せるようになるんです
しかし 心は思考の世界のまんまです
ですから とにかく思考を成り立たない
知識成り立たないような心を成長させなくては
育てなくちゃいけないんですよ
で これは私は批判としては言いたくはないんで
私はその方々 立派な方々だと知っているし
でも うーん まあちょっと勉強してくださいって気持ちもあります
あまり頭でっかち 硬くしないでね
伝統に凝り固まらない
だから認識手段を教えたでしょう
だから特に仏教の場合ははめられているんですね
伝統を守る バカやめなさいとブッダが言うんです
臨済宗の坊さんであっても
なんでしかんたさやって悪いんですかね
しかんたさやってる坊主では
なんで臨済の瞑想をやってみないんですかね
だからこの伝統に凝り固まっちゃうと
悟りはない 解脱はないんで
それだけ 解脱はなくなっちゃうと仏道じゃないんです
だから本当に知らないうちに仏道蹴っ飛ばしてるんです
ですから あの伝統にはこだわらない
文化にはこだわらない
師匠にもこだわらないという客観的に観察するという道が正しいんです
これは私の意見です どうもありがとうございます
どうもありがとうございました
どうもお話ありがとうございました
以前 長老のお話を聞いたのが 3年前なんですが
その時にちょっと質問時間がなくて
ちょっとできなかったので
今日テーマとちょっと直接関係なくて
なんかちょっと個人的な
すごく個人的なことで申し訳ないのですが
質問させていただきます
実は私 今のところ現代医療では治療は不可能と言われている目の病気を患っています
で 進行性の病気で 将来もしかしたら目が見えなくなるかもしれないという可能性を残している病気です
... あの これ付き合うに際してですね
とてもあの 覚悟を決められなくて困っています
この病気をどうにか治るように
将来治療法が確立されるように祈りながら
願いながら生きていくのか
あるいはどうなっても構わないということのように
自分がこの病気をきちんと受け入れて覚悟をして生きていくべきなのか
そのようにも迷いながら覚悟を決められずに生きている状態です
大変繊細な質問かもしれないんですが
私はどういう どういう覚悟をしてこの先生きていけばいいのかというところですね
長老のお考えを聞ければと思います
はい 今 あんた 2つ苦しみがあるんですね
一つはあなたの病気 病気そのものも苦しいし
それについてあなたはあれやこれやとね
考えたら 治療法を見つけてほしいやと思ったりとかね
あんたいろんなことを妄想して
もっとダブルパンチですね
だからダブルパンチ一つにしましょう
まず 世界治療ないというならばいい
あなた方はさようならで
これね 生命っていうのはね
肉体を地球から取るんだから
だから買い物するような感じでしょ
業で買い物をするんで
体を で これは業の場合は一回買い物で返品は不可能なんです
普通の買い物と違うところはそれなんです
だから あなたの業であなたは体を買ったんだけど
その体にはちょっと欠陥があるんですね
返品不可能だからね それなりに手当てしながら使うしかないでしょ
テープを貼ったり ビニール紐で結んであげたりとかね
例えば買った品物に欠陥があれば
返品も不可能だったら
我々はなんとかなんとか
それ手当てをして一応使うんですね
だからそれなりに苦しみはなるになるんだけど
まあそれなりに手当てをしながら
じゃあまあ死ぬまで使ってみますということでね
ということで ポジティブからポジティブとは言いたくはないんだけどね
結局はそれしかないんだからね
ポジティブネガティブっていうことじゃないんですね
生活するしかない 逆に開き直ったらどうですかね
だから何をと 気にしないよと
期待もしないよと その都度その都度対応しますと
例えば目も見えなくなるかもという
予測はあるんだけど これは必ずそうなるかならないかな
わからないしね だからちょっと視力が弱くなってくると
それなりにいろいろまあ工夫してみる
例えば面白そう 目が見えなくなっちゃうと点字読まなくちゃいかんだから
今から点字勉強するそうと
それで点字の知識が身につくし
目が別にどうったことなかったならば
何かプラスアルファでもらってはいる
そういう感じで もう気にしない
だって業で買い物をすると
もうこれは一回一回きりでも返品不可能だから
体入れ替えることできるんだから
だからそれに悩む必要ないんです
自分の業にできる買い物をしたんです
大体業がいいものを買えるのに
わざわざ悪いものを買ったということはないんです
人間に生まれる業に買えられる肉体を買っているんです
だからそれで開き直るしかないんです
我々も時々あるでしょ
このブランド品欲しいんだけど
やっぱり金がなくて買えないんですね
そうするとでも欲しいんだから中古品買っちゃうんですね
仕方がないでしょ まあ中古品買ったらなんだかちょっと納得いかないあるんだけど
開き直れていいでしょうに
そういうことは人生ですよ
精神的に落ち着いてください
そうすると体があなたに迷惑はかけません
あなたは体をいじめているんですね
欲望で 願望で 世の中の知識でね
あの人も元気なのに この人も元気なのに
なんで私だけやって それなんて思考でしょ？結果
あなたは悩むだけでしょ
だからなんでそんなうぶつかけ回すんですかね
そういうわけで だから何をと気にしませんと
それなりに手当 手当をして生きて生きてみるんだと
そう見ると 誰だって同じく生きていることが見えてくるんです
誰だって自分の体に手当をしているだけなんです
特別に私は不幸やとかってないんです
あの人恵まれてるって
それはすべて思考ですよ
主観ですね そういうことで
最終的な答えは別に気にしませんよなんです
それを覚えておいてください
お話ありがとうございました
今回のお話を伺って思ったのが
会社などで目上の人 上司
会社の上司とか いろいろ教えてもらうことも多いですけど
そういった時に自分は特に両親ですとか
そういった目上の上司の方に言われたことをその場で頷いてはいるんだけれども
心の中 結構モヤモヤしながらいろんな仕事とかをするっていう癖があって
そういった時に今回の話を振り返ってみますと
それがそのすごい自分が頑固な面なのか
まだ納得ができてなくて
今日のお話ですと その義っていうのをうまく使えてないのかっていうと
この境目がまだ自分の中でわかっていないので
そこをどう見分けて成長していけばいいのかずところをお話しいただけたらと思います
うん  あの 自分が正しいということはありえないでしょ
それを理解してほしいんですね
自分が正しくないだけじゃなくて
人間誰だって主観で生きているんだから
誰にでも正しいというスタンスは取れないんですね
だから話を聞くと真面目に聞く
真面目に聞いて理解できるところは理解して
その理解できなかったポイントだけ
これをもっと説明してくださいと
ちょっと納得いかないまだというふうに
相手にさらに詳しく説明を聞く方法もあります
で その場で全くわからなかったら
まあよくわかりました
じっと考えてみますと
考えて理解しますというふうに約束してください
だから自分が自我があって
何を言っているのか態度あるとかなり不安になっちゃったんですよ
考える...考え直すこともできなくなるんですね
それから自我はダメなんです
自分が正しいと思うことではもう生きていられません
いつでも考えはもうずっと変わるべきなんです
朝の考えと午後の考えは同じじゃないんです
朝理解しているものと午後理解しているものはもう変わっているんですね
そういうことだから 知識は常に保留なんですね
確定はないんです そうなっちゃうと自我が出てこないんです
柔軟になるんですね 学ぼう
学ぼう 誰からでも学ぼうということになるんです
だからあんたも誰からでも学ぼうということにしてください
学んだからといって正解導けない
正解出てきませんよ それは構いませんね
誰だってなんとなく なんとなく正解のように見えることできてるんだから
完全にはならない もうちょっとね
人の話を聞くべきということを理解してください
大体すぐ解決すると思います
人の話は その人の立場で聞くんです
だってその人は結論に達しているんだからね
どのようにその結論に達しているのいたのかと
達したのかと その立場からデータを自分に取り入れると
自分の頭は自分 頭は自分で
そのデータはどう処理するのかと勝手にやってくれます
自動的に はい そんな程度だと思いますけど
理解できたんですか？ はい
ありがとうございます
はい 先生のご法話で 物惜しみがある人は瞑想がこれっぽちも進まないっていうのがあったんですけど
どうも私の身の回りにもそれに該当するような人がいるみたいなんですが
物惜しみっていうのはなんでそんなに深刻なんでしょう
これって自我ないってことでしょ
結局は自我がありすぎちゃってね
俺だけ良ければもう関係ないっていうね
俺がもともと存在しないんだからね
だから成り立たないんですね
本当に物惜しみは それでもこれ背負っていると
自我がもう固定したまんまで自我破れないでしょ
それだけの説明だと思います
わかりました  スマナサーラ長老
今日はどうもありがとうございました
初歩的な質問で申し訳ないんですけれども
2時間もお話していただいたのに
結局義というものが何なのかが今一つちょっと飲み込めなくてです
手を挙げました 見解 あの
見解から疑が生まれるということでよろしいのでしょうか
先のことが不安だったり
落ち着かなかったりする
あの不安な気持ちのことがいいということでしょうか
すみません よくわからなくて
少しずつだとお願いします
はい 私はすごくいい質問だと思います
消極じゃないんです 疑は一体何なのかと
これはもう勉強しなさい
気づきなさいとずっと言ってきたんだからね
なんか分かりやすい例がないんですかね
疑っていうのは何を知っても
これ決定的なことじゃないんですね
じゃあ昼ご飯時間になった
どこかに食堂に行かなくちゃ
食べレストランに で レストラン 4つある
あなたは 3番目選んだ
あれって決定ですかね？ 3番目の店
店が他４ 4つの店より一番トップですかね
わからないでしょ ただ何かしら見た目がいいとかね
雰囲気良さそうとかね
何か自分が食べたいものがありそう
そんな程度で決まった
決めたでしょ だから じゃああの店で食べましょうと決めたところでも
それが最終正しい結論ではなく
まあまあ仕方がないというね
あの状態は疑いの状態なんです
だからいつでもあるんです
納豆食べれば健康にいいだよと
本当に？と聞いたらそうじゃないでしょ
まあまあいいんじゃないということで終わっちゃうんです
だから何喋っても これは最終決断
決定っていうことはない
何考えても 私は最終的に正しく考えたってことはない
冬休み もうお正月の休み
家に戻るかないか 東京にいるかと
まあなんか悩むんですね
じゃあ家に戻ると決定したんだから
家に戻って本当に楽しいんですか？東京にいるよりは
それよくわからない だから常に義がこうやってなんとなく曖昧状態を作って
不安な状態を作っているんですね
それに義と言うんです
それは正解知らないからなんですね
そういうふうに理解してください
正解は知らない だからそれなりのベターな判断をすると
ベストは知らないというところは疑いというふうに理解するんです
いつでもあるんですね
うん だってあなた この質問する時でも疑いがあったでしょ
こんなこと聞いたらちょっとまずいとかね
テーマは疑いなのに 疑いの意味が消えちゃうとまずくないとかね
思ったでしょ？だからそちらに猜疑があったでしょ
はい  ありがとうございます
はい では ここの方から先に
すみません 今 先ほどの話なんですが
疑が先ほど疑が消えると預流果に達するということだったんですけれども
預流果に達した人は そしたら疑がないので
何もかもすべて何も正しいことがわかるということなんでしょうか
一部わかるんですね 例えば自我中心で嘘を言ったりとかね
生命を殺したり そういう罪は犯さないんですね
でも人間で生きるためには知識が必要なんですね
その時はもう普通の知識だから
もう必ず正しいわけでもないんです
しかし 罪を犯すことはしません
そんな程度なんです 預流果に達したっても
間違う時は間違えます
これは知識世界なんですね
しかし ブッダの真理は間違いあるとは
その人はいくらでも思わない
無常に間違いあるとは絶対思わない
そういうところなんですね
判断間違ったりはします
はい  はい 本日の話の中で論争をしない
相手を打ち負かすのではなくて
理解をする 議論をするというお話がありましたけれども
私は企業のリーガルディビジョンにいて
裁判の対応をしたりですとか
クレーマーに対して会社の正当性を主張したりですね
あるいはこちらに何か不利な点があったら
それを隠すのはいけませんが
ちょっと小さくして有利に相手を打ち負かすようなことをしているというふうに
本日のお話を聞いて思ったのですが
こういう仕事は仏教的に見てどういう評価になるんでしょうか
やっぱりあのローマ教皇が言ったように
人を助けてあげてないと合法的な収入にはならないんですね
だからそこら辺どうにか手を打たなくちゃいけないんでしょうね
だから完璧じゃないね
いくらなんでも 俗世間で正解はないんですね
仕方がなく  4選択肢の中で一つを選んだだけの話なんですね
ラーメン選んだ うどん選んだか
ご飯選んだか 洋食選んだか程度のことで
どちらでも体に悪いだけで終わっちゃう
だから悪さ少ないものを選ぶという感じになるんですね
特に裁判的なになってくると
もう弁解することが仕事になってるでしょ
それで気持ち悪く終わっちゃいますね
結局はね 弁解して勝っちゃってもね
いろんなデータごまかしたりして
もう話術であれやこれやとか
裁判官も脅したりしてとかね
だからもう負けた人ってかわいそうやっていう風にも思ったりはする
だから 俗世間ではいつでもそういう気持ちからは抜けられないんですね
だから 悪は少なくするっていうことに決めてください
それしかあなたの場合はそれしかないと思いますね
しかし 普通に生きる場合は論争しない
議論するっていう方がよく立派な生き方なんです
弁護をする時でも やっぱりそこ人格できちゃうと正しく弁護できるんです
問題なく 例えば会社がもうこう言わな
そうやったって本人言ってることは正しいです
だからそこら辺は裁判かけないで認めましょうよと
その方が楽だと それは言えるんです
人格あるならば この場合は
向こうはもう当然間違ってるんだから
もう会社で戦わなくちゃいけないんだと
いうふうに問題ちゃんと来る前に理解して判断に対することできます
そういう場合は結構損が少なくするんですよ
戦わないで事前に判断するとね
そうすると優しいやりとりだから
向こうもあの 英語のフレーズありますね
ワンパウンドなんとかあのマーチャントオブベニスってあるでしょ
あの肉 アントニオから 1キロ欲しいやと
そこまではいかないんですね
そういうことで 生きる上で
あの...議論するが論争しないという立場で
法律になってくると論争が仕事になっているんだからね
世界はわがままだからそうなっているんですよ
世界の生き方の間違いは法律で派手に表しているんです
いつでも間違っていると化すという
悪人が化すというシステムになっているんです
そういうところでね で
ノーイービルではできませんだから
レスイービルで でもやるしかないでしょ
はい  わかりました  はい
では最後に質問の方  ちょっと聞きにくいことで今まで一度も聞けていないのですが
疑ということで やはり宗教団体にいますと
あるものに 例えばリーダーに疑いを抱いている人はいられなくなるっていうのがあると思います
なので私はどの宗教に団体も所属したことはないんですが
この仏教の教えっていうのは
ブッダの教えに対してまだ疑問がある
そういうものが勉強したいと思っていられる場所なんでしょうか？ そうそう
別に疑問があったら正直にそれは認めた方がいいんですね
ですので ブッダの教えは信仰ではなく
ちょうど科学であって
地球が丸いのと一緒だというおっしゃっていますが
地球がちゃんと丸いとは思っていませんけれども
ですが ブッダの教えが真理ならば
それに対する疑っていうのは犯罪になるということですか？ ああ
ちょっとこんがらがっちゃったね
すみません  ブッダは真理を語られていると私たちは言う
言ったんだからと鵜呑みにするなよと
調べなさいよと ブッダが自由に調べる自由があげているんです
だから自分ではこれはわからない
これはわからない これは納得いかないとかね
疑を持って勉強すればいいんです
だから疑は機動力になるんだからね
あれは罰が当たりません
ただ単に感情的に非難侮辱することは悪行為なんです
これは他の宗教団体に対しても感情的に非難侮辱すること
悪行為なんですね だから私がやっているように
ちょっとニコッと笑ってからかってみると
これは楽しいだけで終わっちゃうんですね
感情的に何も思ってないんですね
ですから このブッダのこの話はけしからんとか感情的ではなくと
ちょっと理解できません
これはちょっと納得いきませんとかね
そういうふうに思って構いません
思って勉強していくんですね
ありがとうございます
疑いがなければ勉強しないんですよ
だから仏教は信仰という
このそれはもうやめてよと
確信 信仰の代わりに確信しなさいと
信仰っていうのは条件なく
ただ信じた終わったなんですね
確信は仕事をしないと
確信するために調べないと
だからブッダの教えを調べて調べて調べて調べてまくったところで
やっぱりブッダの教えは正しいという確信に達したら
それしてから人は成長します
信仰はまず要求するもので
仏教の信はこれアフターロングスタディなんです
長くスタディしてから達するものなんです
その差なんです 信という単語は仏教でもあります
確信なんですね はい 以上です
はい それではちょうど時間となりましたので
これで本日の講演会を終了したいと思います
はい 最後の聖歌を一緒に唱えましょう
ドゥッカパッタチェニン
ドゥッカ バヤッパッタチェニン
バヤ スーカッパッタチェニン
ソーカ ホントゥサンベピパーニノー
苦しんで悩む生命が苦しみなく
恐れて悩む生命が恐れなく
悲しんで悩む生命が悲しみなく
一切の生命が安穏でありますように
どうもありがとうございます